[Music]
happy Thursday reject nation Greg Alva
here John humph
we're gonna watch the trailer for How to
Train Your Dragon numeral grass the
hidden world s sake I'm excited to check
this trailer out the first one was a
pure delight the first trailer the other
two movies are terrible no one liked and
as a heads up we're gonna be dividing up
the reaction in the review part of this
because of the fact that we've had some
videos for them certain companies get
blocked and just in case this gets
blocked but people still want to know
our opinions about it we're gonna put
our review of this trailer on a separate
video which should be up right now as
well isn't that funny covering all basis
don't worry some people were like I
think it ruins the flow if you stop and
if I'm like no guys we've filmed them
running the same take dividing up the
video but listen before we go into this
I want to say thank you to everyone
who's been following some start us at
people over there we do 30-second
reactions for films TV shows and
trailers we propose daily on there and
having a blast we are past seven
thousand followers right now so thank
you so much for doing that guys it's
worth it a lot of youtubers are on there
so make sure to down the app and follow
us first it's free to use free to
download everything about it's free this
is not even a paid shout out so we're
just doing it because we love using it
do it now this is
attic it was the war with your
grandparents and we are nine pins before
that what out there beyond the age of
the one why is the home of the Dragon
and I believe that your destiny to one
day find it slayed him hey slaughter
them in there
[Music]
[Music]
this is a new kind of enemy
we need to find the hidden world I will
destroy if criminal succeeds there won't
be any dragons left and it's up to us to
put an end to it boys cry what are you
gonna do about it
suit up gang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow it really does
but this
[Music]
not a word that looks like a really fun
film I got a lot of thoughts got some
thoughts things to say why don't you
guys hop on over to that trailer review
now see this end screen here hit it the
card hit it if you don't have any that
turned on don't be lazy just type it in
hit it this video might be blocked soon
so now's your chance to go hit a card or
that's great yay